i'm going to start with the big question
as a fan of the series i need to find
out if tim cook actually watches this
thing
because i would figure that if he does
it's going to be on the air a long time
uh i've heard that he is a fan of the
show apple has been really supportive of
the show
in so many ways and uh yeah hopefully
uh we can uh be on for a long time
yes i need that to happen so you guys
you guys after season one um you get
picked up for season two
i'm curious at that moment how much are
you starting to think about okay we
better figure out a five-year plan
or did you already have that prior to
season one
actually one of the earliest
conversations we had matt and matt main
ron
we discussed a plan moving forward
decades in terms of what
this show what the timeline of the show
would look like
from this moment of the russians landing
on the moon first so
we're prepared uh to take the story uh
far into the future
and i think the exciting thing of the
season two and now a pickup for season
three
is it really allows us to kind of jump
forward in time and show
how this the impact this kind of change
really had on history
well something that i'm curious about is
you guys are dealing with the changing
decades
and with season two we move into the
early 80s
if the season if the show continues is
there going to be a point where you see
yourself sort of like starting almost
with a whole new cast
because you know there's people can only
get so old
and be participants in the nafa program
i mean in terms of the characters
there will be characters that phase in
and out of the show
you know it's just innate the nature of
our show is that
uh you know otherwise by season six
we'll have a bunch of 130 year old
astronauts uh
but um uh so we're constantly
introducing
new characters but i do think we have a
plan where
uh to ben's uh reference about our our
sort of
uh very early discussions about about
the
full scope of the show there are
characters that will go through the
whole way
and some that won't so it's sort of a
mixture of
of all of the above yeah and it's not
just new characters it's also
recasting characters who are kids in
earlier you know the kids in season one
we retest them as
so there's a mix and match but also i
have to say that
the technology now and the makeup
effects that are available to us is
insane like you can
you can really do a lot in terms of
aging and we did a lot even with season
two in terms of the
the ten year jump as you saw um in terms
of those changes so i think
you know i think there's we look at how
people change and
i think that informs us but yeah
depending on how long the show
goes that will definitely come into
question at some point
um have you already thought about what
season would introduce a starship
um that's uh we're still figuring that
one out we're still uh
we're not sure but we're headed that way
you know i mean we're definitely headed
towards so funny it's like
seeing the news now of all the things
that are
that are happening um
in the real space programs and with
spacex and with uh
yet you know what nasa's doing and now
there's there's all these uh
countries sending unmanned uh missions
to mars and
it's so fun to see uh things we talk
about in the room
unfolding in real life now i think it's
you know so
the sky's the limit definitely you know
early on we talked about this show being
a more like
about more hopeful future and i think
that is where like the the star trek
comes in an idea of you know
what that helpful future can be so i
feel like
while there will be a starship i think
every year you will see the technology
um expand and increase and i don't know
it'll get cooler and i'll get into
areas that we aren't as familiar with
you know i think season one was a lot
about like oh i remember that i remember
that
season two starts to be like wait i
remember that but that that looks a
little different that's so
it's it starts to evolve and i think by
season three it'll just be
a lot more stuff you we're not familiar
with at all you know the sea dragon i
think is a great example of something
that
it was an idea conceived in history i
mean there were blueprints for it and
everything but it was never created
so we that's the promise of the show
really is that you can take these
these ideas and bring them to life i
feel like that that
like the sea dragon there's there's
other little things that are coming up
like that uh i get it one of the things
that i want to talk specifics but i
can't one of the things about
one of the things about this series is
that there's a lot of characters
and there are so many places where you
could spend
the entire season just with the general
and dealing with the pentagon or the
military aspect or just
you know there's so many places you can
spend time what is it like in the
writers room trying to figure
out we have all this this huge canvas
where do we want to play
it's exhausting it's it's there's a lot
to keep track of and and uh you know
it's it's one of the things i love most
about the show is
is the the breadth of the characters and
the different stories we get to tell but
it's we also have to be very
economical with our storytelling and how
we present those moments and finding
even if a character isn't really
featured in an episode finding a moment
to um give them a a way to move their
story forward
and then uh you know certain
episodes will focus more on that
character so it's
it's really we talk about it kind of as
a symphony where in different parts of
the symphony different instruments rise
to the four
even and then they'll go in the
background but they're still a part of
the piece of music
obviously you guys know i'm a fan i know
you got picked up for season three
uh where are you in the writing process
of season three right now
um we are as you know we're just
finishing season two and we started
we're in the writers room for season
three right now so we're
we're kind of with the writers through
zoom which is definitely a little
different um
but coming up with ideas it's been a lot
of fun i guess they were very excited
about the season three pickup and the
and the confidence apple has in us uh
but also the ability to take this story
even further into the future
or our history is really exciting so i
think right now we're writing
starting the script soon and uh yeah
we're gearing up for it so
we're pushing ahead when you are writing
the scripts
how much of the season is actually
finished before you start filming
and how much is it sort of like your
writing as the season is going
well the goal at the beginning is always
to have all the scripts done before we
start shooting and then that never
actually happens i think first season of
fargo was the only time we were ever
we had all the scripts ready before so
it really just depends
i think uh with season two it was kind
of a
mixture we had maybe three or four done
before we started and then
we were writing as we went um and one of
the fun things about a television show
is you see
how characters how new characters uh
play in the first couple episodes and
you can write to that so there's a lot
of revisions that also happen where
oh that thing we thought was going to
play in the writers room isn't really
playing so we need to adjust that
and that's one of the really fun parts
about
uh about producing a tv show
do you guys end up with a lot of deleted
scenes or not really
not you know not really actually i think
there are some but
but looking through i mean look i think
inevitably certain episodes go too long
and you have to do it and it's painful
but i feel like for the most part there
aren't many scenes that we've
we've cut um overall
yeah uh i guess i'm curious
were there story lines you came up with
with season two
that couldn't be worked in due to time
budget
that you're like that's a great story
we're bringing that season through
um let me think well it's tricky because
of our time jumps a lot of times the
story lines
uh are based in that period of history
so it's it's tricky to do that so a lot
of times
there are stories that come up in the
room that i love that we have
we just don't have the room for anything
like matt said earlier this
we have a huge ensemble and i think part
of what makes the show work really well
is the
not the village just to show astronauts
but to show the engineers to show the
families like
we'd love to be able to show all parts
of the ensemble and i think in order to
do that
you do have to you know you have to give
up on some ideas that we
that we really love so it's hard but i
think
in the end you end up with the best
stories you know when you have to go
through that process
as a writer you find out it's painful
but it gives you the best result usually
and to add to that while it's not
necessarily like story lines i do think
sometimes there's scenes like there's
definitely a few awesome death scenes
we've come up with over the last couple
years that we
we wound up being like maybe we
shouldn't kill off that character at
this point and then we couldn't use that
death scene but
they're still uh you know it was fun to
have those in our heads uh
at some point we have a very creative
room very blood thirsty but creative
that's my last question for you because
i think i'm gonna be out of time with
season two
the big like set that you got to add was
the jamestown set which is
incredible um yeah it seems like every
season of a tv show you get to build one
new set
have you already thought about what that
new set might be on season three
oh yeah oh yeah can't say much more than
that but we definitely
i mean what's funny about our shows
because we jumped so much in time we
actually
we we we built a lot more new sets every
year than
a regular show and we and we retire a
lot of sets so it's definitely
um there's gonna be a lot of fun new
stuff in season two and in season three
yeah i mean the show gets bigger and
bigger every year really i mean the
nature of this
is the more you go into the alt history
the more you go into science fiction and
so yeah like matt said we have to it's a
reset every year but it's exciting you
know the challenge is you know we're
gonna have something big
that you haven't seen before every
season of the show so
yeah it's coming i wish i could say more
but
it's you know it's i i get it i'm just
gonna say as soon as you finish nine and
ten please send
um and listen uh have a fantastic
afternoon thanks for the great work
thanks